[Musique]
800 kg par an par pêcheur en france là
vous vous dites c'est forcément le
volume de poissons
raté c'est beaucoup moins de l'amour en
fait c'est le volume de sud est pêche
estimé usagers jeter en déchetterie
enfin quand ça ne finit pas abandonner
sur les quais parce que pour info un
filet de pêche
c'est au minimum deux kilomètres de long
alors je vous laisse vous imaginez ce
que cela représente
ces 2 kilomètres mais moi quand je les
fais en courant
je les trouve l'on sait de kilomètres de
plastique car oui le plastique pas
fantastique a pris toute sa place dans
le matériel de production des pêcheurs
excite les filets en coton mon cher
moins abrasif le plastique est devenu le
matériau unique dans le matériel de
pêche et ceux des jets termine mélangé à
nos déchets ménagers qui finissent
enfouies ou incinérées
alors j'ai dit et je dis mais avoue
trouver des solutions en faisant ce
constat désastreux je ne suis pas là
purement et simplement en train de
fustiger les pêcheurs ce serait trop
simple
la société bien plus complexe que ça
depuis que j'ai débuté ce talk
vous avez sûrement en tête ces images
aient crié par les médias or là c'est la
pêche industrielle
moi j'ai envie de vous parler de ce qui
vous sourit quand vouloir acheter le
poisson frais sur les quais ceux qui
pratiquent la pêche artisanale
oui c'est ce patron pêcheur bien souvent
seule à bord sur son bateau qui mesure
entre 5 et 10 mètres de long et qui va
caler ses filets en fonction de la
saison et qui subit de plein fouet le
déclin de la faune avec une équation
simple plus de pollution plastique moins
de poissons égal moins de revenus et
cerise sur le gâteau les politiques
économique territoriale et nationale
s'intéresse peu ou pas à cette filière
et bien moi oui j'en ai fait mon métier
pourtant je ne suis pas fille de pêcheur
je ne viens pas des métiers de la mer
non je suis une fille de la forêt de la
savane j'ai eu la chance de grandir dans
des milieux riches en biodiversité la
guyane et le kenya ait cette chance elle
était complété par ma mère ancienne
navigatrice et par ou deux
elle fait partie de ces femmes fortes
qui m'inspire de par leur force de par
leur passion pour ce qui les entoure
puis un jour elle m'a embarqué j'avais
11 ans nous avons rallié en cinq
semaines la guyane jusqu'aux açores et
j'ai mis le pied dans ce qui est
aujourd'hui mon univers
mon moteur j'ai puisé ma force premier
mon caractère et puis j'ai vu ce qu'on
ne souhaite pas voir les déchets j'ai
passé des semaines à m'émerveiller des
deux fins et amauri fier des déchets
voire des casques de chantier des
emballages de bonbons la font partie de
mes souvenirs d'enfant et je vous parle
de 2005
on parlait alors peu de cette pollution
en mer mais cette graine avait germé
dans mon esprit n'a cessé de pousser en
en venant m'installer à marseille il ya
six ans un nouveau choc vient booster
cette envie fondamentale d'agir lequel
ne plonge à la ciotat
je me suis de nouveau émerveillé de
cette fois de marine et encore une fois
je me suis horrifié de cette pollution
plastique et ceci a fait rejaillir en
moi cette fameuse traversée est une
forme de colère sourde s'est installée
et j'aurais pu tout simplement
m'inscrire dans une association
militante contre les pêcheurs pollueurs
non j'ai fait tout le contraire
à 22 ans j'ai eu envie d'agir j'ai eu
envie de reconsidérer le filet de pêche
non pas comme un dégel et comme une
ressource
il a donc six ans je suis sorti de ma
zone de confort un cdi en tant que
naturaliste
aujourd'hui c'est une évidence en fait
j'ai créé mon métier spécialiste de
gestion des déchets de la pêche
or de nature très curieuse j'allais voir
un premier pêcheur puis un second qui
est en troisième j'ai lu énormément de
rapports vu beaucoup de reportages
j'ai même questionné mon entourage qui
avait des idées assez étroite sur le
sujet est très peu d'intérêt pour ces
hommes et ces femmes qui partent chaque
jour en mer et puis un jour je me suis
retrouvé avec ce déchet dans les mains
je discutais avec un pêcheur au vallon
des auffes à marseille soulagés de voir
que quelqu'un s'intéresser enfin à ce
sujet il m'a remis ces deux kilomètres
de filets que j'ai bien une mal à
remettre dans ma c1
méchaal est sûre
quoi en faire et comme la réponse était
peu existantes très peu connue de
chaillé chercher par moi même et c'est
comme ça que je suis devenu cette
spécialiste de gestion des déchets de la
pêche
aujourd'hui je n'avance pas à pas pour
créer ces filières de valorisation
défila usagers en maintenant un contact
permanent avec les principaux intéressés
les pêcheurs artisanaux depuis 2016 je
fais face à des obstacles mais ma
détermination reste intacte
le premier l'absence de chiffres
officiels sur le volume de file est
produit par an par pêcheur en france
alors tu es tu es bille en tête
il ya six ans j'ai réussi à m'inscrire
et un atelier sur les déchets marins au
niveau national
surprise générale je n'ai pas entendu ce
jour là que les pêcheurs avaient des
besoins non qu'il fallait les
sensibiliser bon après ce propos bien
catégorique j'ai présenté le témoin les
témoignages d'un pêcheur qui était bien
conscient des enjeux environnementaux
des enjeux qu'il subit j'ai eu droit à
une des réponses très constructive à
écouter mademoiselle mais les pêcheurs
dans que faire dans l'environnement
je vous invite donc à retourner en stage
ou à l'école nador le mans faire avancer
les choses avec ça non c'est pas grave
j'ai continué sans relâche à comprendre
les enjeux environnementaux et les
enjeux sociaux de cette pollution des
filets
guy d'épargné des fixes ça ne donne pas
ni les moyens ni les outils nécessaires
aux pêcheurs mais la gestion des filets
n'évoluera pas alors en 2019
je sautais d'un grand bain
l'entrepreneuriat je souhaite aller plus
loin je souhaite créer des filières
personnalisé où le diagnostic est
l'accompagnement implique d'emblée les
pêcheurs jamais je ne les considère
comme le problème non mais toujours
comme porteur de la solution avec moi et
ça marche
les solutions émergent aujourd'hui avec
mon partenaire recycleurs bretons il
régénère les filets de pêche polyamides
en granulés à destination d'entreprises
qui souhaitent intégrer cette nouvelle
matière un exemple les lunettes que je
porte sans ton fils mais
elles ont été co créée par de grandes
marques d'optique française en 2021 la
région occitanie sera la première de
méditerranée à voir sa filière
personnalisé sur la gestion et la
valorisation des filets notre objectif
est simple dupliquer ces filières en
mélangeant les savoirs des uns et des
autres pour avancer sur cette
problématique et je protège donc à ma
manière notre environnement pour trouver
et pour considérer non le filet comme un
déchet mais comme une ressource à
travers les différents partenaires et ça
marche
aujourd'hui avec les pêcheurs mon numéro
se diffuse dans leur communauté ils
veulent changer leur image autant que
leurs pratiques et je n'oublierai jamais
une chose
non jamais les que les premiers à
m'avoir soutenu à m'avoir fait confiance
à nos conseillers à me guider sont et
resteront les pêcheurs alors si on
arrêtait de porter des jugements binaire
et hâtifs changeant de lunettes
les gentils et les méchants ce sont dans
les histoires pour enfants
la société n'est ni blanche ni noire
elle est grise enfin verte et bleue car
nous devons sans délai y remette la
nature au centre de la société
mais ceci est mon avis mais j'espère que
vous êtes serez nombreux à le partager
et agir pour merci
[Musique]